but let's stay with the world of
business and ask one of the key
questions just exactly how much does a
pint down your local cost you those
living in london myself included could
soon be paying as much as seven pounds
for the privilege industry experts say a
mixture of rising inflation supply chain
issues and high labor costs
means that pint prices may be set to
soar
joining us now clive watson chairman of
the city pub company which runs around
50 pubs in the south of england clive
great to see you this morning um
say it isn't so are we about to enter
the era of the seven pound pint in
london at least
uh i think that's probably a little
right at the top end but certainly
six six pounds plus is is going to be
the norm in those london pubs
what do you attribute that i mean as
mentioned in the introduction there
people are complaining about rising
costs inflation and so on energy prices
but it also strikes me that january is a
pretty quiet month in the best of times
and these are not the best of times
well that's right uh but the increases
are going to come through in the way
that you've already suggested energy
costs big increases there
uh labor costs minimum living wage
nothing wrong with that but that's going
up as well you've got cost of food going
up cost of your beer products wines
going up so it's a cop an inflation
cocktail heading our direction and of
course vat
is going back up to 20
on food as well come april and employers
national insurance so there's lots and
lots of big costs heading our direction
and that's going to inevitably mean the
price of a pint going up
i mean a simple question then clive do
you think that those who regularly go to
a pub are willing to pay that much i
mean the last time we saw mass exodus of
customers from the pub trade was when
the smoking ban came in are we
approaching a point at which you know
the unit cost of a pint for the consumer
may well prompt them to stay at home
with their cans instead
i think that's a good question and i
think
whilst the
an econo economists would put up the
price to beer by say 40 50 a pint i
think you're absolutely right there's
only so much that the customer will
stomach so i think actually pub company
is going to have modest increases and
have to take the rest of the costs that
they face on the chin so the consumer
will pay a bit more but the pub
companies will have to dip into their
reserves
just in terms of of the assistance
that's currently uh
on display from the from the government
i mean is there more that they could be
doing right now to help out hospitality
in general
well i mean the vat increase in april uh
they should certainly suspend that
i think one that is across all
employment sectors is the employers
national insurance and the employees
nation
insurance hike
in april i mean that's just
bonkers basically that's a tax on jobs
and that's the tax and low pay and and
that just to me doesn't make sense so i
think certainly suspend the v80 increase
which is
due in april and scrap the national
insurance increases in april
what what do you think what are your
hopes or fears perhaps um for the for
the hospitality industry in particular
you're part of it
moving forward i mean you have you have
50 pubs i think i think i've drunk in a
few of them anyway but do you do you
believe that you'll have that same
amount of pubs this time next year
yeah i do because our balance sheet is
strong but for a lot of independents who
don't have access to other shareholders
to support them it's going to be tough i
mean they've had limited sales over the
last two years
uh
if hopefully we're coming out of this
pandemic great sales are recovering but
then you've got all these cost increases
and they need to make money
to pay back the debts that they incurred
over the last two years so it's going to
mean a contraction in the sector and
that's not good for the government
because they'll they'll raise less
revenue from the hospitality industry
we're probably one of the most taxed
industries there
so if you actually nurture the industry
in the long run you'll make you'll
get more money for the exchequer
clive watson chairman of the city pub
company thank you so much for joining us
appreciate your time